à mieux ben oui mais on est obligé vous
avez dans un tas de s'oxygéner et quand
on n'a pas le temps d'aller à la
campagne il faut bien avoir un appareil
à la maison c'est à dire en regardant
cette scène vous avez utilisé vous même
le terme d'insolence moi je dirais selon
ce passive
oui à se lance aussi dans la douceur
dans le oui c'est ça c'est un monsieur
un petit peu en retrait qui voit les
choses sont sans violence c'est vrai
qu'est ce qui vous a plu dans ce rôle
parce que vous avez a dit tenir à ce
rôle de nestor du non ont pas le rôle ce
poste que tu as pas au rôle doses si
vous voulez je tiens au film parce que
je trouve que dans le cinéma comique en
france on fait des choses très bien très
drôle mais qui sont si vous voulez des
choses qui existent depuis un moment
j'ai souvent l'impression de voir des
films qui aurait pu être tourné il ya
une trentaine d'années je pense qu'on
peut rire avec des films qui ont été
tournés ya 30 ans c'est pas je dis pas
des choses méchantes en disant ça mais
je trouve aussi quand on a l'occasion de
lire une chose un peu original et
surtout aussi peut-être avec un metteur
en scène un jeune metteur en scène qui
n'est peut-être pas l'expérience de 40
ans de métier mais l'expérience nuit à
je pense à l'invention
si vous voulez alors je pensais que
c'était pour moi et pour lui cette
proposition une une choses excitantes
pour un comédien l'excitation j'allais
dire c'est c'est du comics en agitation
eh bien oui mais pourquoi pas un oui oui
sans hésitation oui y'a pas y'a pas de
grands mouvements vous n'avez pas besoin
de faire des fêtes autour est ce que
dans ce qui sort de votre vous aidant le
ton est donné
et puis il ya aussi des choses que
j'aime beaucoup dans le fil
personnellement en tant que comédien ce
sont des moments qui sont à mon avis des
moments clownesque où tout est basé sur
la présence physique de choses par
exemple la scène si vous avez une film
dans le dans la voiture ce bras quand il
est là avec avec sa secrétaire et qui
dit je sais pas ce qui m'arrive 7,7 me
ravit il ya d'autres choses comme ça que
j'aime beaucoup quand ils entourent son
petit doigt qu'il enlève son pansement
et ce sont des états de deux comiques
pur voyez j'ai une grande faiblesse pour
les clowns et jeu si vous voulez pour
moi c'est une un petit retour
y a des envies comme ça un petit peu
rentrée vous aimeriez de clown ah oui
mais vous savez cadres d'être comédien
je voulais de clown et déjà fréquenté
une piste auront oui bien sûr on vous
verra un jour
ab j'espère mais l'ennui c'est que vous
connaissez aussi le cirque à vous avez
des dix entreprises ou si elle vous avez
organisé des choses et vous savez que
medrano un disparu et qu'on joue le haut
2 fois par semaine ou trois fois par
semaine au cirque d'hiver et dans une
ville comme paris je trouve que c'est
bien dommage mais je j'adore les clones
et au passage je remercie par exemple on
parle un peu tout je voudrais saluer
zavattin que j'estime personnellement un
grand clown est depuis longtemps que je
connais en tant que spectateur je ne
connais pas personnellement mais je
voudrais vraiment le chercher parce que
je trouve que il avait vraiment de génie
de la piste extraordinaire dans le film
de jean yanne vous allez faire le clown
oui voilà alors vous savez à chaque fois
se présente un peu la manière qu est ce
qui va se passer ça c'est de la farce de
la comédie dont on peut jouer dans le
film de de diane je crois que j'avais
une comédie un petit peu poussé mais je
parlerai pas de farce
une comédie satirique où je pense les
acteurs auront intérêt à servir le texte
met à jouer l'intrigué l'histoire le
scénario qu'il a écrit
ouais je dis quand même pour pour ceux
qui nous regardent il s'agit de deux
heures moins le quart avant jésus-christ
que vous tournez en ce moment avec jean
yanne en tunisie et au vous joins le
rôle de le juge les a le césar avait sa
véritable jules ben oui c'est un
véritable jeu louis ben oui mais c'est
normal je parle je parle
oui c'est normal de jouer césar c'est le
dollar la progression des déserts et
puis j'en ai clement u2 alors n'est ce
pas ça leur a donné des idées sans doute
en tout cas nestor burma va sortir le 14
avril nestor burma détective de choc
alors qui réussit il nomme qui réussit
je voudrais aussi quand même
n'est ce pas pu donner à tous les deux
que tous les deux je voudrais parler
aussi des gens qui sont avec moi de jane
birkin et je serai ravi de gt1 vie de la
rencontre et je la connaissais bien sûr
mais je trouve qu'on fait un couple qui
m'amuse beaucoup une espèce de chose
insolite de rencontrer un mélange de
générations qui m'amuse beaucoup et puis
la présence de mon grand ami
guy marchand fin vous savez les acteurs
sont des gens étranges on marche par
affinités par coups de foudre
disons que je vous avais de refuser un
rôle s'il vous plaît pas à simplement
bien merci
michel serrault 14 avril donc ce film de
jean luc hees à jean luc miesch jean-luc
michmich sur vos écrans nestor burma
détective de choc